[Music]
foreign
so we finally saw what the most of us
has in store for us and God damn this
has made me more excited than a husky in
the open snow we did a breakdown on the
teaser that was recently released and
while doing so we couldn't help but
imagine where or what the ape titan is
its Origins its powers for now we shall
call him red Kong or maybe even Crimson
gong if you guys want a second option
but make this viral so here in this
video we will tell you about five
theories on what red gong is and also
his Origins so let's get to it
number one a newly awakened super
species so this is the first Theory and
the ape title might be a new species
that has been in hibernation or in a
deathless slumber for millions of years
not unlike Cthulhu and has just recently
been awakened what evidence do we have
to support this well as it is just a
30-second teaser that was given to us
everything is pure speculation if it is
a new species that it would explain as
to why the synopsis of the movie reads
as this latest entry follows up the
explosive showdown of Godzilla vs gong
with an all-new cinematic Adventure
pitting the almighty Kong and the
Fearsome Godzilla against a colossal
undiscovered threat hidden within our
world challenging their very existence
and our own it will also explain why it
is slightly different in design to Kong
while Kong has a heavy build and this
one looks to be taller lankier Slimmer
and has red fur and also this Titan more
resembles an orangutan in arm length and
also for color this would entail a new
dominance game between him and the other
two Apex Titans
the theory number two a renegade or an
exiled ancient Kong so for the next
Theory this red car might very well be
just another Kong specimen but was
actually the cause of the ancient war or
at least a survivor of it the new Empire
is expected to showcase the Titan war
between Godzillas and gongs that
occurred millions of years in the past
that led to the expulsion of Godzilla to
the surface as well as the remaining
calms migrating to Skull Island since
the hollow Earth would have become a
Barren Wasteland due to the conflict the
red car might really be the instigator
of the war maybe exiled for the same
reason and now reawakened by Godzilla's
Atomic breath destroying the throne room
a once demonized Kong would surely be on
a Vengeance campaign against not just
Godzilla but gone as well since he would
hold the latter as The Descent number
three a bioengineered Titan okay so the
third theory is that the red Kong is
actually a bio version of mechanical a
bioengineer Thailand by another decision
Corporation or maybe even a clone of
Kong created by Apex Industries after
the destruction of Mechagodzilla the
reason behind it is that now Humanity
views both go and Godzilla as tyrants
that can and will cause massive
destruction to civilization and for a
reason that is just Primal in nature so
if we have a Mecca form of Godzilla in
the last movie what's to stop Humanity
from cloning a biofarm of Kong the one
that actually brought the robot Beast
Down in the last movie and this clone
version to be even more powerful than
calm but this will go against the
synopsis that reads it was a colossal
undiscovered threat hidden within our
world etc etc anyway this makes for a
good storyline don't you think so and it
would for all intents and purposes put
Humanity in the chess table as well and
not just witnesses to tyrants
number four a mutated calm species
so okay what if gong wasn't the only
specimen of his species alive and there
is yet another population of Kong
surviving in the hollow Earth and
gradually over the years they have built
a sedentary quiet life in a far corner
of the Subterranean ecosystem and just
like how the Eerie stories until the
Godzilla swallowed a star meaning the
power Souls thereby transforming him
into a Titan that possesses the atomic
breath and other energy-based powers
what if the same thing or one of the
gods did the same thing and now has
grown to be taller lankier as well as
have let's say superpowers this would
explain the glow in the eyes of red Kong
the same bluish glow that Godzilla has
this mutated Kong would not only possess
the power to kill our hero Kong but also
with this intelligence be a monster that
could overthrow Godzilla from his Apex
position therefore be a threat to both
species and also to humanity since the
Newton could command the other beta
Titans like Behemoth Methuselah Silla
and and all the others to do the same
thing that Ghidorah did in king of the
monsters
and number five maybe he is an evil
subspecies and for the last theory on
his Origins it would be that this
actually is another subspecies of gong
that was once held as an unimportant and
overlooked by the other Titans in the
hollow Earth there is a basis for this I
assure you so if you remember dog the
hollow Earth lizard well his species is
actually a close relative to the titanus
Gojira species and who's to say that
there are no subspecies of gong as well
smaller ones that could grow over time
and when left alone for thousands of
years without any competition or
predation they would eventually grow
into gigantic proportions the subspecies
of red gum could be the opposite of the
black Kongs with the latter being a
noble lineage of simeons the former
might be the evil counterparts and also
what if both of them coexisted in the
ancient bars and that it was the red
Combs that instigated the war with
Godzilla and now both species are almost
extinct with only it and come as remnant
of a bygone age
so that's it I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till next one take care
fam